Rebecca kiesling lost both of her sons
if you can imagine that to fentanyl her
18 year old son Kyler and her 20 year
old son Caleb both were poisoned in 2020
when they took what they thought were
percocet pills but they weren't for
fentanyl yesterday Rebecca kiesling
testified in the house of represent him
she pointed out that our government
isn't doing anything to protect
America's young people from this
if we had Chinese troops lining up along
our Southern border
with weapons aimed at our people with
weapons of mass destruction aimed at our
cities you damn well know you would do
something about it
we have a weather balloon
from China going across our country
nobody died and everybody's freaking out
about it
but a hundred thousand die every year
and nothing's being done not enough is
being done numbers are going up not down
you're welcoming drug dealers across our
border
you're giving them protection you're not
protecting our children
Rebecca Houston joins us tonight excuse
me thank you so much for coming on
um you certainly made the point to the
Congress do you think they heard you
uh more than half of them did
but I was really appalled at some of the
rhetoric that I heard honestly from the
Democrats
saying that they've heard a lot of fear
of mongering like are you are you
kidding me like a hundred and ten
thousand died
in 2021 like we have a reason to be
afraid China is going after our children
we've got rainbow fentanyl now in candy
boxes coming to this country and now
they're mixing fentanyl with a horse
tranquilizer so that Narcan won't work
so it can't be detected by fentanyl
strips like
they're trying to kill off our
population and you're going to accuse me
and the others testifying that we're
fear-mongering
so you lost both your sons to poisoning
by a foreign government and you're a
fear Monger they
you know what was your reaction I can't
even it's hard even to believe that
happened what was your reaction to
that's so disgusting well I was really
upset by the guy from the Cato Institute
who testified that the pro the problem
is demand
and that's like some of the rhetoric
that I've heard on social media since I
testified people saying oh they wanted
it
you know like they were doing something
illegal so they deserved to die
and people didn't used to die from
experimenting with drugs and I of course
I taught my children not to do drugs
they heard it more than anybody else
because their birth mother was a drug
addict
but they still experiment in any way and
unfortunately over a hundred thousand
are and they're dying they still deserve
to be protected
it's a health issue they deserved real
help but they deserve to be protected
from an attack by as you said a foreign
Nation
well I mean they didn't take fentanyl
they took what they thought was Percocet
and like so many young people they were
poisoned to death by something that was
mislabeled I mean no different from the
Tylenol murders that took place 40 years
ago where people put Sina and Tylenol
they thought they were taking Tylenol
they got cyanide I mean and but the
libertarian response was it's their
fault they deserve it
right that's what I'm seeing on social
media there's some people that are
extremely callous I mean how
cold-hearted can you be
um to speak to me like Dad to to say
such horrible things that they deserve
to die and that I was a horrible mother
and somebody should have called CPS I
mean they know nothing
about what happened and how much I tried
and how I sought help for them through
the school through the police I mean
they have no idea what I went through to
fight for them
well we we've interviewed a lot I know
personally a number of parents in your
position and to blame you for it or your
children who died from poisoning is
really we'd really have to be the Cato
Institute to do that so I'm sorry you
had to hear it Becky keesling thank you
very much
thank you for giving me this opportunity
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight